[Musik]
alex w
in der beschreibung ja leute bevor ich
wieder losgeht weil ich noch ganz gut
sagen ich habe mir noch diese ps4 ist
jetzt nämlich schon aufgemacht wollte
ich eigentlich nur zeigen dass ich
wirklich ne psp also jetzt wirklich apps
hier drin
ich will das jetzt nicht ganz aufmachen
weil sonst hat er das gewinnen am ende
eine urkunde ps4 und wir haben hier auch
noch ein iphone ab das sind die letzten
beiden klassen gewinne meiner dezember
verlosung so dafür habe ich mir jetzt
folgendes überlegt als erstes wird die
psl verlost und zwar verlosen wir die
heute und morgen in dem video wie kann
man daran teilnehmen fälle die es immer
noch nicht mitbekommen haben die
verlosung ist natürlich immer für all
meine abonnenten gibt dem video doch
nach oben und schreibt heute einen
kommentar unter dieses video und genau
den gleichen kommentar müsst ihr morgen
unter dass wir beschreiben was halt
morgen und mein können von unter altes
wochen wird halt die vers 4 verlost und
ich kann auch bei der presse sagen die
bringe ich persönlich freue mich vorbei
und halte das auch gerne auch wie du
fährst jetzt viel spaß mit dem video
macht das bitte auf keinen fall nach vor
allem an die etwas jüngeren von euch das
muss ich auf jeden fall sagen und let's
go
[Musik]
hey leute was geht ab jetzt gekommen
beim ein video ja leute ich hoffe ich
geht es gut ich wollte gar nicht so laut
sprechen weil es gibt ja schon menschen
die schlafen auf jeden fall habe ich mal
wieder eine nächtliche aktion geplant
wenn gerade so ungefähr 11 uhr und wir
suchen uns jetzt ein platz für
hoffentlich ungestört sind und nicht
wieder die polizei kommt so wie bei der
letzten aktion niemand kurzer ausschnitt
und dann kommt ja weil ich glaube
diesmal wäre es wirklich da ist ja noch
nicht erlaubt offiziellen spielen ja
mittlerweile schon über 14 das half mir
nicht also fahren jetzt los ist gleich
wir sind jetzt schon eine halbe stunde
unterwegs war ist heute was mache ich
auf jeden fall suchen wir einen platz
sowie das umgestellt machen können und
überall sind halt irgendwie so häuser in
der nähe und man kennt ja deutschland es
gibt so rentieren sofort die polizei
rufen oder so auch wenn es jetzt
eigentlich nur kindergarten ist man muss
ja nicht sein dass schon wieder die
polizei kommt irgendwann reicht auch
also wir gehen jetzt zu irgend so ein
fahrradweg und ja mal machen wir das
einfach so leute ich hab ja irgendwie
noch gar habe ich schon gesagt was ich
heute überhaupt vorhaben nein eigentlich
ganz einfach wir machen folgendes auf
jeden fall mir ist aufgefallen ich habe
schon sehr sehr lange nicht so viel
gemacht habe heute wieder ein bisschen
eingekauft wir haben hier cherry kiss
ist und ich würde sagen passend zur
silvester zeit also beides ja silvester
neues jahr
hast du es auch gehört ja dran so soll
das lkw erhalte risch machen ich
ungemein geh mal weg lkw und ich auf
jeden fall habe ich vom letzten jahr
noch 5 d bilder gefunden hast du
erstmals natürlich sagen leute macht das
auch keinen fall nach dollar sind es ab
18 und erst wenn er 18 seid dürfte damit
auch was machen also das ist ganz ganz
wichtig wie man sieht das ist hier
komplett abgesperrten gelände jedoch
niemand drauf und deswegen sind wir die
menschen sicherheit wir haben eine
baugenehmigung und deswegen sind uns
absolut sicher dass wir mitten in der
nacht irgendwo bei nation dürfen ein
spaß also wir müssen halt ein bisschen
aufpassen und zu habe ich so videos
gesehen da haben leute wie lucas rakete
gemacht und ich dachte mir wenn ich noch
so china debelle habt mal gucken ob
dieses bild das aushält
gut was ja ich wollte dass ich zu dran
bin oder nicht ist schon der strecke
sache auf jeden fall ich werde schon
wieder irgendwo mann sitzt jetzt hier
irgendwo ein fenster und hat schon mein
kennzeichen notiert und sieht auf jeden
fall
die fed hat sollte also ohne wird eine
stange dynamit leute ohne witz nenne ich
mal hier aus sieht man den gleichförmig
wir weiter guckt euch diesen transport
verhindern was macht man denn bitte
jetzt auf seinem parkplatz der iss an
ja das wollen wir sieht auch das ist
schon gruselig aus so leute berlin ist
nicht genüge klar ich könnte jetzt auf
die andere seite seitlichen parkplatz
und ich hoffe hier ist jetzt kein mensch
ich nämlich auch man richtig heftig okay
leute also wir haben jetzt einen böller
daran auch so ist dafür jetzt
wahrscheinlich direkt geld kommen
jetzt kommt im fußball einsetzt so alles
wollen
das war das war schon laut man zerstört
nein null oder ein bisschen braune
bisschen aber ich dachte da passiert
mehr wo wir besser woanders hin ja ich
meine da ist also die kinder sozial sein
so leute also noch wirklich jetzt kommt
da hinten ein auto da kommt der
fahrräder kann's einfach nicht drin
wir sind jetzt hier auf jeden fall auf
dem sehr abgelegenen platz recht niemand
lang fahren kann oder lang kommen kann
ich weiß auch gar nicht warum ihr diese
laterne brennt aber natürlich doch die
erinnerung macht das auf keinen fall
nach das ist wirklich sehr sehr wichtig
es sei denn ihr seid alt genug ich
glaube jetzt die vierbeiner muss man
seinen 18 18 muss man seine führung
solange ich habe das jetzt fertig gebaut
meine gangs damit wieder hobby setzt was
mein lieber kameramann christian rath
noch mal gesagt hat das habe ich nicht
zum spaß gesagt solche bilder sind
wirklich gefährlich man kriegt ja unter
18 nicht aber wenn so ein ding in eurer
hand explodiert dann kann auch eure hand
immer gut ab deswegen ist die finger
davon wenn ihr zu jung sei dank alles
jetzt kann's losgehen waren also ich hab
das jetzt so geplant ich werde einfach
dass sie angst und dann das der einlegen
und dann hoffe ich dass alle böller
explodieren oder nicht gewonnen schon da
irgendwie das sei eben perfekt
eigentlich dass das mandat zu machen
macht das überhaupt keine flieger mehr
kontrollen jetzt darin liegt dass ich
dann so gut drauf man hier drauf ja okay
leute
ja wir gucken dass ich noch ein jahr
[Applaus]
es ist echt heftig doch vor allem war
das richtig halt feststellung des
unzerstörbaren haben wir heute noch dass
man den 0 mit
also wird wieder mitgenommen wir sind
echte vorbilder wenn wir hier guckt es
ist halt schwarz aber ist es nicht mal
so ansatzweise eine obwohl doch auch
hier ist eine beule oder siehst du das
aber das hätte ja auch abfliegen können
oder also dieses spiel ist ein stabiles
denkt na ja als wir es angezündet haben
sind zwei explodiert danach noch mal
einer
wir haben es hier noch ein so wir noch
eins hinterher kommen wenn schon denn
schon
wir wollen dass auch eigentlich recht
positiv also das war mit abstand der
lotsen und da kommen jetzt schon ein
paar auto
das war schon das verhältnis war jetzt
das riecht verbrannt oder aber das ding
das ist einfach noch ganz rechts gebaut
von ihm ist das noch mal vom baby und
baby also mit sicherheit hat wie wir
wirklich gedacht ja ja leute also schaut
euch an funktioniert mit und jetzt
richtig auch wieder gut da kommen das
fahren benutzers eigentlich alex
natürlich die heute hier nochmal im
tageslicht so sieht die branche jetzt
ausbaden sind auf jeden fall drin
nur ich hätte echt nicht gedacht dass
die so krass stabil ist das war jetzt
natürlich auch keine mega krassen böller
aber ich dachte schon ist ein bisschen
mehr anrichten vor einer mehrere auf
einmal aber war aber nicht so ich hoffe
dass wieder hat euch gefallen
schreibt kommentar und wir sehen uns
dann morgen wieder morgen gibt's nämlich
auch ein cooles video haut rein